okay I've talked about the importance of
not ignoring the resurgence of
neo-nazism and white supremacy and the
alt-right under Donald Trump because
ignoring it will allow it to be
normalized ignoring it will provide
cover for legislation to be passed and
now we have Republican Alabama Senate
candidate Roy Moore who is in a primary
runoff next week he is now referring to
Native Americans and Asians as reds and
yellows here is a clip of Roy Moore at a
recent event hear it from the horse's
mouth himself party against party what's
changed now we got blacks and whites
fighting rich yellows fighting Democrats
Republicans fighting men and women
fighting what's going to unite us what's
gonna bring us back together a president
the Congress know it's going to be
comfortable yeah
what an inspirational message of hope
unity and bipartisanship of course Red's
a pejorative term used to refer to
Native Americans it dates back a long
time I think the European arrival in the
modern United States yellow dating back
also arguably to Carl Linnaeus but also
connected to the Chinese surname Huang
translating literally as yellow the
response from Moors campaign the
comments were taken out of context of
course they were if that was the full
context but they're not what more Connie
played the context for you like what
broader context would there be if Roy
Moore his name rings a bell it's because
we've covered him before he once said
that the First Amendment protects only
Christians he once ordered judges in his
state to defy a federal gay marriage
ruling he once wondered aloud whether he
would end up giving his life someday to
stopped gay marriage I guess the answer
there is no and he once likened gay
marriage to Nazis I'm not even really
sure what that actually means what is it
with conservatives having this
romanticized view of the past - well
like in past generations we never had
conflict between groups and things that
were just we're not as bad as they are
today yeah it's this idea of sort of
returning to some golden era and
depending on who you're talking about it
could be the 1950s it could be the slave
era it could be some other arbitrary
point that is what they've decided is is
the sort of golden era of humanity of
sorts and are there conflicts between
Native Americans and Asians now as he
points out I really can't think of any
example well I mean there might be
individual conflicts like we could
probably find an Asian guy that has a
problem with a Native American person
somewhere who lives on the street who
lives somewhere on a street yeah but
it's not exactly yeah that's a good
point it is that even really true what
Roy Moore is talking about here now I
want to let you know there is an
alternative in Alabama his name is Doug
Jones he supports universal health care
public schools living wages protecting
Medicare equal pay for equal work as
well as renewable energy now he's in the
general election which is going to be
December 12th we're still in the
Republican primary you do need to
register to vote by November 27th in
Alabama if you want to vote here
is a great race that you could get
involved in if you are in Alabama go to
david pakman.com slash reddit to discuss
this and any other stories you want to
from today's program
today's episode is made possible in part
by blueSky a binary there are millions
of forex traders around the world and
80% of them lose money and I actually
have been dabbling in forex trading
since I was like 16 years old and I've
lost some money doing it and usually
when people lose money in this it is
because they either lack the appropriate
knowledge they might be relying on
others auto traders or other traders
they follow instead of themselves
sometimes people get emotional or take
bigger risks than they should or not
understand or follow proper money
management rules and blueSky binaries
education course sort of helps to
mitigate every single one of those risk
factors they're a leading financial
education and tech company focused on
forex they've got senior trading traders
with real trading experience offering a
structured and self-paced course that
you can take video on-demand online
tests one on one education sessions and
access to their community of traders are
all part of that course david pakman
show viewers and listeners can register
right now to get a free one-week trial
at blue sky binary.com / david that
includes access to their training
platform and a session with a senior
trader to go over the basics if you want
to continue after that it's $99.99 a
month you can stop or resume at any time
once again that's blue sky binary.com
/div ID